en el vídeo pasado empezamos a platicar
acerca de la demanda agregada que damos
que era una variable macroeconómica le
voy a poner aquí macro para acordarnos
que es una variable macroeconómica y
dibujamos su gráfica la comparamos tanto
con la versión microeconómica y dijimos
que también como esa tenía una pendiente
negativa deja le pongo por aquí que esto
es demanda agregada algo así pero
dijimos que aunque también tuviera una
pendiente negativa la tenía por otras
razones y empezamos a explorar algunas
razones aunque más bien debería de
llamarles teorías por las cuales está
pendiente esta base está esta curva y va
hacia abajo entonces tenía pendiente
negativa las tres teorías que dijimos
era número uno el efecto riqueza para
esto era muy importante acordarnos que
todo era setter y es paribus es decir
considerando que todo lo demás era igual
entonces si de repente los precios eran
más bajos la gente consumía más entonces
le mandaban
que será una de las primeras
explicaciones la segunda era el efecto
de ahorro e interés que básicamente era
que si la gente empezaba a ahorrar más
entonces eso entraba al sistema
financiero al sistema bancario los
bancos podrían prestar más aumentaba la
oferta de dinero bajaba el interés y por
tanto aumentaba la inversión de modo que
de nuevo el pib podría crecer de modo
similar si subían los precios bajaba la
oferta de dinero subía el interés y el
pip se contraía eso de ahí era la
segunda razón y la tercera razón tenía
que ver con un efecto de cambio de
divisas si bajaba el precio pues de
repente las cosas mexicanas se iban a
ver más baratas por toda una cadena de
razones que habíamos puesto por allí
entonces si se oye si bajaba el precio
las cosas mexicanas se veían más baratas
aumentaba la exportación y por tanto
aumentaba la demanda y de modo similar
si aumentaba el precio entonces la
exportación disminuía es decir había
menos demanda porque las personas ven
que era pues más caro comprar cosas
digamos mexicanas bueno esas eran las
tres razones que exploramos pero
lo que quiero hacer es explorar un poco
la idea de cómo le podemos hacer para
desplazar esta curva la curva de la
demanda agregada hacia la izquierda o
bien hacia la derecha como en un cierto
nivel de precio fijo podemos hacer que
se desplace el producto interno bruto
real va entonces para esto es muy muy
útil acordarnos de pues de cómo está
constituido el producto interno bruto
real o bien cuáles son sus componentes y
eso lo voy a escribir por acá arriba
recordemos que ya es la variable para
producto interno bruto y que estaba dado
por la fórmula consumo que es el consumo
de todas las personas más y que es la
inversión que se realizan más
que corresponde al gobierno al gasto
gubernamental más la exportación neta n
x esto de aquí es la exportación van
entonces pues ya viendo cada uno de
estos cachitos cada una de estas
componentes podemos empezar a explorar
qué sucedería con ciertos cambios de
acuerdo a ciertas decisiones que se
tomen por ejemplo qué pasa con el
consumo cómo podría aumentar el consumo
pues no sé a lo mejor puede haber una
disminución de impuestos disminución
acción de impuestos si de impuestos
puestos y qué sucede con una disminución
de impuestos supongamos que el gobierno
decide bajar los impuestos pero no lo
compensa con un bajo de con una baja de
gasto si el gobierno dice no pero voy a
bajar para que la gente tenga más dinero
entonces como la gente ahora tiene más
dinero para empezar a consumir más y por
tanto aumenta la demanda entonces qué
sucede esta curva se desplazan hacia la
derecha así para cada nivel de precio
fijo la gente consume más de modo
similar si hay un aumento de impuestos
entonces ahora la gente
pues tiene menos dinero y está curva se
va hacia la izquierda
en cada punto para cada precio fijo se
consume menos ahora qué pasa con la
inversión vámonos a inversión entonces
pues porque podría aumentar la inversión
pues no sé de modo similar podría haber
una motivación fiscal déjame ponerle por
aquí motivación
motivación fiscal ya que de repente el
gobierno diga
pues va a estar o sea este año las
empresas que inviertan van a pagar la
mitad de sus impuestos o algo así
entonces algo de ese estilo también
puede hacer que aumente la la inversión
o no se incluso podría ser que se
descubriera una nueva tecnología o
nuevos recursos o una nueva rama de la
industria entonces lo que hace eso es
que muchas personas empiecen a invertir
allí verdad empiezan a invertir en esta
tecnología o en esa rama eso otra vez
hace que haya una mayor inversión
entonces hay el producto interno bruto
aumenta de modo similar si disminuye la
inversión porque ahora hay impuestos a
la inversión lo cual sería un poco tonto
pero pues pensemos en algo así o si de
repente ya pues hay un negocio que ya no
tiene pues muchas muchas posibilidades
de seguir o lo que sea pues ya también
va a disminuir la inversión y por tanto
la curva se desplaza hacia la izquierda
vamos con el gobierno
lage es del gasto gubernamental entonces
el gobierno de repente puede decidir
pues empezar a gastar más incluso puede
ser que ya esté gastando lo más que
pueda y pidan nuevos préstamos préstamos
se hace en deuda más para tener más
dinero y que con eso pueda gastar más
dinero entonces como es un componente
del producto interno bruto también hace
que la curva se desplace para allá o se
corta algunos gastos y entra en ciertas
políticas de austeridad entonces esto se
desplaza hacia la izquierda finalmente
tenemos esto de acá que pues es muy
intuitivo verdad la importación y la
exportación le voy a poner aquí la n x
entonces pues qué podría pasar si de
repente pues en méxico nos damos cuenta
que hay un producto así súper padre que
podemos exportar y a la gente le encanta
y encontramos una forma de promocionar
los súper bien no sé valeroso maracas o
lo que se nos ocurra entonces esto va
aumentar la exportación neta aumenta el
producto interno bruto aumenta y esta
curva se desplaza hacia la derecha si
por el lado contrario tenemos que
importar muchas cosas o dejamos de
exportar maracas o lo que sea entonces
esta curva se desplaza hacia la
izquierda entonces esas de ahí son las
posibles razones por las cuales puede
desplazarte desplazarse esta curva y
pues están más o menos
de recordarnos más o menos es observar
cada una de las componentes del producto
interno bruto y luego pensar qué tipo de
decisiones macroeconómicas afectan cada
una de estas componentes y cómo éstas
van a hacer que la curva se desplace
hacia la derecha o hacia la izquierda